hello everyone and I do say hello
everyone with such enthusiasm because
today is a great day for chess and the
world in general today in round 18 of
the Chinese chess League and immortal
game was created it was created by the
Chinese Grand Master ding li Ren he was
playing with the black pieces against
the by Jing Chi another Chinese
Grandmaster and this game I'll let you
be the judge of that but I'm pretty sure
it can rival any immortal game you've
previously seen especially since it's
played today in modern chess in 2017 so
like I said by Jin she has the white
pieces and he plays d4 Knight to f6 by
the illyrian c4 e6 Knight to c3 and
Bishop to b4 the names o Indian Defence
and the by Jin she doesn't go for a
three or a three some of the old lines
he goes for Knight to f3 the three
Knights variation of the names of India
ding clearing castles we have Bishop to
g5 and c5 III see capture Sundy for
Queen captures on d4 Knight to c6 and
Queen to d3
so far all is well h6 and now either
this Bishop will capture the knight or
go back Bishop to h4 was played at d5
rook to d1 now g5 Bishop to g3 and knife
to e4 centralizing this Knight that's a
very powerful piece in the center also
if white doesn't react to this maybe
even f5 is an idea later we have Knight
to d2 now I'm pinning this c3 Knight and
preparing to capture on e4 dinkler and
responds with Knight
the c5 would attempt on the Queen Queen
to c2 and here dinkler in plays d4 and
okay it's definitely an interesting move
we have Knight to f3 which is the best
move and now I think we were in place
well an interesting move to say the
least he plays d5 and what do you do
here I mean it obviously it's a free
pawn
so definitely white must capture it by
gene she plays Knight captures on e5 and
this is the best move we have d captures
on c3 think we were and offer
a queen sacrifice and my game by gene
she accepts it as it is definitely the
best move rook captures and e8 and we
have C captures on b2
now with the discover check from the
bishop on b4 here King to e2 was played
and this was the critical moment of the
game ahead by Jean she played rook to d2
he could still be able to play this game
black would probably keep small edges
white pieces are all pretty much
undeveloped but he would definitely stay
in game but after after the move in game
after C capture sambito with Czech and
King - E - it's pretty much pretty much
over for white rook captures on d8 we
have queen capture some b2 and now
Knight to a4 would attempt on the Queen
Queen to c2 and now Knight the c3 with
Czech and the King hunt begins we have a
knight King to f3 and here comes the
move that when he probably had to see
before he decided to sacrifice the Queen
and this is why I enjoyed this game here
there are a couple of moves that well
might seem interesting for example f5 to
lock the King there on f3 or maybe even
h5 to prepare a move like Bishop to g4
after you capture this knight on e5 but
Dingley Rijn finds is definitely the
best movie plays rook the d4 and this is
beautiful the rook is now cutting off
the king the King can go anywhere you
can't capture the rook if you capture
the rook you get to Knight captures on
d4 black is winning the Queen he is up
too much material and he is winning the
game
so after up to d4 h3 was played adding
some protection at the g4 square and
also making an escape route route for
this bishop on h2 so maybe the King will
be able to go to g3 we have h5 by the in
clearing now Bishop to h2 and the g4
King to g3 and now rook the d2 again
with the tempo on the Queen the Queen
cannot capture the rook because of the
same reason as before Queen captures and
E 2 nights 3 4 check white loses the
Queen and the game as we have to rook to
the
Queen to b3 was played and now Knight to
e4 would check and the King has to come
up the board King to h4 Bishop to e7
check King captures on h5 now kink to g7
and the King on g7 is actually an
attacking move add England is preparing
this light-square bishop to jump into
the game and then this rook is coming
from a it all the way to h8 to join the
attack
Bishop to f4 now Bishop to f5 preparing
rook to h8 and now Bishop to h6 would
check King to h7 and it seems that a
white prevented this idea of rogue - h8
but as you'll see not really Queen
captures on b7 and now there are some
threats white can capture the rook white
can capture this night if the knight
moves white and captured the bishop but
again doing Weaver and finds the
absolute best move rook captures an f2
he grabs a pawn and he doesn't grab pawn
because Dingley are in like spawns it he
grabs it because this f2 point was
guarding g3 now if white plays a silly
move like rook Queen captures rook on a8
then night the g3 is checkmate
so after rook captures an f2 of course
the the White Queen cannot capture the
rook rook the Bishop to g5 was played
now we have worked to h8 Dingley reign
is preparing a king to g7 and we have
Knight captures on f7 I would attempt on
the rook Bishop to g6 with check King
capture son g4 and here Dingley run
played Knight to e5 with check and in
this position by June she resigned the
game white King has two options he can
either capture the night would not
capture Sonny v or he can go to King to
h4 whichever moves
move he plays he drew loses in three
moves or in two moves if Knight captures
on e5 if Knight captures on e5 Bishop to
a5 would check King to h5 and now King
to g7 with check Bishop has to block
Bishop to h6 now white checks back and
rook captures an h6 this is checkmate
and another move after this Knight to e5
check is King to h4 but the this leads
to an even greater checkmate
after king to h4 after king to h4 King
to g8 with check now sacrificing a rook
and Knight captures and Bishop captures
Bishop on g5 this is checkmate
but after Knight to e5 check by Jin
should resign the game this is moved 32
and this amazing brilliant immortal game
whatever you want to call it was created
by Tingler
leerin and this is I find this amazing
that in 2017 2017 is almost over it's
November a game like this can still be
played against against the Grandmaster
like by Jin Xiu who is I believe the
2550 his peak rating was somewhere
around 2600 so playing again again like
this against the Grandmaster is is why I
enjoy chess and I'm sure many of you do
as well so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I haven't enjoyed I
enjoyed a game like this in quite a
while
so I'm definitely gonna be following the
Chinese chess league a lot more from now
yeah I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here I would like to thank Sanjay
Santana and an unknown person for your
contribution to my channel thank a lot I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon
oh yeah and I will only be doing one
video today I hope you don't mind I have
some work to do
unfortunately so two videos tomorrow see
you soon